hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry and calm and in this video we're
going to go over how to solve dopamine
calculations and after you watch this
YouTube video you can access the free
quiz that will give you more practice
over these calculations so let's get
started first let's do a quick
pharmacology review over dopamine this
drug is a beta adrenergic agonist which
means it acts as a vasopressor with
positive inotropic effects now what does
this mean well these oppressors what
they do is they perform vasoconstriction
they really press down that vessel make
it narrow and whenever that happens that
will help increase blood pressure
increase the semuc vascular resistance
and increase our cardiac output so
dopamine can be used in some patients in
certain types of shock where they're
experiencing severe hypotension their
cardiac output is low or their systemic
vascular resistance is low and you throw
on the dopamine and that can help
increase those values in addition
because of dopamine's positive inotropic
effects it increases the heart's
contractility which means it helps the
heart pump stronger
another thing dopamine does in low doses
about 0.5 to 3 mics per kilogram per
minute is that it can actually cause
renal vasodilation so the vessels that
feed our kidneys will dilate which will
increase perfusion to the kidneys this
can help increase our urinary output the
reason it does this is the way that the
dopamine affects those dopaminergic
receptors in the kidneys now whenever we
start getting into high doses of
dopamine about 10 mics per kilogram per
minute it actually has the opposite
effect you'll have constriction of those
vessels that feed the kidney so only in
low doses do you have the dilation now
dopamine is administered IV and it's
best given through a central line now
why is that why don't we want to give it
through a central line rather than
the basic IV cannula round well dopamine
is a major vasoconstrictor so if
extravasation occurs where dopamine
accidentally leaks into that surrounding
tissue it can lead to tissue ischemia
necrosis so as a nurse you've really got
to watch that infusion site and if this
does occur what medication can be given
to help in a sense reverse those
vasoconstrictive effects you can give
santal Amin which causes vasodilation so
remember that drug for your vasopressors
dopamine the infusion rate is anywhere
between 2 to 20 Mike's per kilogram per
minute this infusion rate really depends
on the parameters set by the physician
as a nurse you will be titrating this
drug based on whatever the physician
wants that patient in and some other
things you want to remember with this
drug the patient will need to be on
continuous EKG monitoring looking at
that rhythm dopamine can significantly
increase the heart rate so looking at
the heart rate looking at their blood
pressure monitoring that constantly
their urinary output as well because the
way that dopamine can influence the
perfusion to the kidneys and of course
watching that IV site now let's do some
practice dopamine calculations our
problem says a patient is ordered to
start an IV dopamine drip at 10 Mike's
per kilogram per minute the patient
weighs 55 kilograms you have a bag of
dopamine that reads 800 milligrams per
500 MLS what will you set the IV pump
rate at so to solve this problem we need
to know three things first the patient's
weight because dopamine is weight base
and we're told the patient weighs 55
kilograms second the dose how much is
ordered and what's ordered is 10
micrograms per kilogram per minute and
then third what is available to us this
bag of dopamine that we have how much
does it contain well we're told we have
a 500 milliliter bag that has 800
milligrams of dopamine now what we're
trying to get to is the milliliters per
hour because this is what we're gonna
set our IV pump out so it can achieve
this order dose based on this patient's
weight and what the physician wants so
to solve these problems I like to use
dimensional analysis and if you're not
familiar with how to set up dimensional
analysis I have a whole series you can
access that will show you how to do that
and I will be rounding these answers at
the end to the nearest tenth but for
your nursing school always follow their
rounding rules so what I like to do is I
like to start out with the way and this
one's easy because normally you have to
go to pounds and kilograms but we're
already in kilograms so we'll start out
right with that so 55 kilograms is how
much our patient weighs now what's
ordered is it says for every kilogram
this patient weighs they need 10
micrograms per minute of dopamine more
patient weighs 55 kilograms so one
kilogram is equal to ten micrograms per
minute because that's what they want
so we're kilograms cancels out and we're
trying to get to milliliters per hour
okay so right now we're in micrograms
because we're talking about 10
micrograms and our bag is in milligrams
so we're gonna have to convert because
we need to get there so we know that a
thousand micrograms equals 1 milligram
thousand micrograms equals 1 milligram
that cancels out our micrograms so now
we're in milligrams now we can plug in
our dose that's available so we have a
bag that has 800 milligrams of dopamine
and 500 MLS well we're trying to get to
milliliters per hour but we're at
milliliters per minute right now that's
what's left over so we're gonna go ahead
and solve so we're gonna multiply
everything at the top and everything at
the bottom so 55 times 10 times 1 times
500 is 200 and
seventy-five thousand and then one times
one times one thousand times 800 is 800
thousand then we're going to divide that
out when we divide that we get zero
point three four three seven five
milliliters per minute but we're going
to get two milliliters per hour so how
we're gonna do that well we're gonna set
this up over here we know that there are
60 minutes in one hour and with this for
every minute we're gonna give point
three four three seven five meals so one
minute equal to 0.34 375 milliliters
minutes cancels out we're now in
milliliters per hour so 60 times point
three four 375 gives us 20 point six two
five and when you multiply that at the
bottom of course that gives you one and
you divide that out we're gonna round to
the nearest tenth will give us 20 point
six milliliters per hour that's our
answer our next problem says a patient
is ordered to start an IV dopamine drip
at five micrograms per kilogram per
minute the patient weighs a hundred and
eighty pounds
you have a bag of dopamine that reads
400 milligrams per 250 MLS what will you
set the IV pump at so to solve this
problem we need to know those three
basic things that we discussed before we
need to know the weight which is 180
pounds the dose which is five micrograms
per kilogram per minute and what's
available to us we have a 250 ml bag of
dopamine that contains 400 milligrams
and we're trying to get two milliliters
per hour because that's what we're gonna
set our pump at so let's start out with
our weight and here we're gonna have to
convert to pound from pounds to
kilograms so the patient weighs a
hundred and
and we know according to the metric
table that there's 2.2 pounds in one
kilogram so 2.2 pounds in one kilogram
so our pounds cancels out we're
following kilograms so now let's plug in
our dose the dose says for every
kilogram my patient waves they need 5
micrograms per minute of dopamine so one
kilogram is going to be equal to 5
micrograms per minute kilograms cancels
out here we're trying to get milliliters
per hour now we need to do some
converting because our bag is in
milligrams and right now we're still in
micrograms so we know from the metric
table that there's a thousand micrograms
in one milligram so micrograms cancels
out and now we can plug in what we have
available to us and we have a bag it
contains 400 milligrams and 250 MLS so
we're gonna go ahead and solve we're
gonna multiply everything at the top so
180 times 1 times 5 times 1 times 250 is
225 thousand and then multiply
everything at the bottom 1 times 2 point
2 times 1 times 1000 times 400 is
880,000 and then when we divide that out
we will get 0.25 5 6 8 1 8 repeating so
that is milliliters per minute but we
need to get to milliliters per hour so
we're gonna do a little bit more
dimensional analysis and we know that
there are 60 minutes in one hour and we
know with this what we've calculated for
every minute they will be receiving 0.25
0.25 5/6 a18 repeating so one minute is
equal to that
and when we multiply that at the top at
the bottom what are we going to get
we're going to get fifteen point three
four zero nine PT and then we're gonna
round to the nearest tenth and our
answer will be fifteen point three
milliliters per hour okay so that wraps
up how to solve IV dopamine drip
calculations thank you so much for
watching don't forget to take the free
quiz and to subscribe to our channel for
more videos